Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This piece of work shows us how to render
a piece of cloth down to the level of fibers.
This is a difficult problem, because we need
to be able to handle models that are built
from potentially over a hundred million fiber
curves.
This technique supports a variety of goodies.
One - level of detail is possible.
This means that the closer we get to the cloth,
the more details appear, and that it is possible
to create a highly optimized algorithm that
doesn't render these details when they are
not visible.
This means a huge performance boost if we
are zoomed out.
Two - optimizations are introduced so that
fiber-level self-shadows are computed in real
time, which would normally be an extremely
long process.
Note that we're talking millions of fibers
here!
And three - the graphical card in your computer
is amazingly effective at computing hundreds
of things in parallel.
However, its weak point is data transfer,
at which it is woefully slow, to the point
that it is often worth recomputing multiple
gigabytes of data right on it just to avoid
uploading it to its memory again.
This algorithm generates the fiber curves
directly on the graphical card to minimize
such data transfers and hence, it maps really
effectively to the graphical card.
And the result is a remarkable technique that
can render a piece of cloth down to the tiniest
details, with multiple different kinds of
yarn models, and in real-time.
What I really like about this piece of work
is that this is not a stepping stone, this
could be used in many state of the art systems
as-is, right now.
The authors also made the cloth models available
for easier comparisons in followup research
works.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!